disneyland reopens after being closed
for more than a year that's a cnn
business story disneyland
uh but many healthy safety protocols
will continue to be enforced
the capacity of the theme park in
anaheim california will be significantly
limited to comply with the
health safety requirement and promote
social distancing i think the number is
capacity in addition until further
clarification from the state to
california only california residents
are allowed to visit the disneyland
resort uh theme park so if you're out of
state like we could not go to disneyland
in the state of california
in groups no larger than three per
household three i mean you got what if
you got two kids
they'll turn you around you have three
kids
health safety measures include
requirements face coverings for all kids
two years old an
older two-year-old temperature
screenings for all guests entering the
park cashless transactions and capacity
limitations at
attractions disneyland's union have
pushed california governor newsom to
reopen the park
earlier this year group of california
state assembly members also proposed a
bill aimed at speeding the reopening
disneyland and other large theme parks
in the state so i'll go to you first
major williams what do you think about
that
well i i you know i think it's been
overextended
in regards to the the lockdowns and um
i don't know it's just i mean look at
the dynamics you know
how they're limiting and creating this
fear and just this hesitation that's
happening i think it's bad
culturally i think it's bad
psychologically and i just don't get
like the rationale the common sense
aspect of it i think um
it's once more it's it's not even
overreach right it's not like overage
it's just like
silliness at the end of the day so it i
can't there's no elaboration on it it's
just it's just
it's just ridiculous yeah if you were
governor what would you do in this
instance
how would you what would your disneyland
policy be well i don't know
i don't i don't know the the reach of a
governor when it comes to disneyland
well you got security you can get on
every ride you want
right away there's no lines man when
you're governor
only with two people ultimately relax
i don't i don't know like i said that's
something you wouldn't delve into is
what you're saying
i mean i i believe that um
you know from a statewide perspective in
policy you know it would be very
transparent in regards to where i stand
when it comes to that but i think it'd
be a little bit harder uh
legally and legislation-wise when it
comes to some company like disneyland
you know one of the good things is i
don't know if you saw this but when you
enter disneyland now the snow white and
the seven dwarfs are offering you free
coveted vaccines i mean they're in there
they're
they're they're they're working hard
this is amazing they're keeping them
busy
this is it are you going to take your
kids to disneyland ah i'm not going to
do it now because it's way too much now
wait a minute
that was a joke yeah that was a joke
uh you know yeah
you know you're gonna see more of this
from newsome unfortunately he's gonna
open up disneyland more and more and
declare it a win
here here's the one thing that scared me
the most i don't know if you guys heard
this kamala harris
addressed the united nations and this
kind of has something to do with
disneyland but
did you hear her say we got to get ready
for the next pandemic
i mean that did you hear her say that i
mean i cannot believe that and it also
makes me think about all those
businesses in orange county
those small businesses the hotels all
the vendors
i mean there are so many businesses that
went under and
it is just so ruthless of what happened
there and you wonder
is he against them or was this a
strategy to shut down some small
businesses
you will have people say that that's
been part of his strategy as well
to literally take out some of the small
businesses and make me dependent on it
but i think
psychologically it's helpful that
disneyland is open it's the happiest
place on earth right you know it should
be open so you you live there why you
wouldn't take your
family i i just want to okay right now
it's like a resident it's way too
complicated i mean
can you imagine you got to make a
reservation i'll do a party of four six
o'clock
friday night yeah pathetic what they're
doing over there why don't we talk about
what you did you did a a how-to board
episode about
what disneyland versus disney world give
us a little insight look it's the exact
same situation i gave you where you have
the eastern conference western country
you have the whole thing with
california and uh you know uh california
and uh
new york against texas and florida the
santa's like look we're keeping disney
world open don't even sweat it and
bob berg bob um iger bob iger who was
sitting on the board
for uh newsome he was helping a new
someone bringing back
you know the the state of california the
moment newsome announced that he's
still keeping a shutdown the next day
bob iger resigned he said i'm not even
doing this and bob
is a democrat who thought about running
for office when he wrote his book you
know the book that he wrote about the
right of a lifetime yeah so here's the
ceo he's got two
you've got disneyland california disney
world florida
he's a democrat he's sitting there
saying listen as much as i'm a democrat
and why are my democrat friends keeping
my place closed and i lost 70 you know
000 jobs and over here they're keeping
it open and my guys over there have jobs
and
small business owners around there
they're staying in business but small
business owners around disneyland that
rely on that traffic
right they're going out of business
speak speaking of bob iger and bigwigs
that are kind of in newsom's camp
um i think a lot of people in silicon
valley just came out
in support of new south wales yeah well
they're all behind what is that story
why are they behind him why is big tech
behind him why is silicon valley behind
him
they're the ones saying that it's a
republican recall
right give us some information i mean
it's in our best interest though so when
it comes down to policy
and legislation and regulations you know
he's always sided with them when it
comes to that so i mean that's a
no-brainer for
the tech industry uh i don't know if
it's like universally with the tech
industry but a big portion of the tech
industry are going to be for the
champion that's for them
and that's what's happening i just want
to talk about uh disneyland once more in
regards to the businesses that have been
affected
the reason why governor gavin newsom can
make those unempathetic decisions is
because he has never personally
physically built a business he's never
had a dream or ideal that he's
manifested
and had that moment when he had that
first sale or had that
that opening or whatever like some of
these small businesses that are
suffering
right so it's hard to kind of lead or
make this make decisions based upon that
like you know you're kind of up here
and that's what uniquely makes me
different you know than
everyone else because i have been a part
of that dream or that aspect of having
that first creative ideal and seeing it
manifest so i know how to govern
when it comes to that and it shouldn't
be one size fit all which is where he
really failed
and i'll say this wholeheartedly
governor gavin newsom could have been
deemed
the best governor of california at the
beginning of all this
but because of busy guided decisions and
his uh
and his uh his stances and and being
seen at french laundry
uh he dropped the ball greatly and uh i
think
essentially i exist because of him and
we're going to punish him for that
in regards to him no doubt you're right
about what you just said i mean
we talked about earlier that he won in a
landslide yeah
and now he's getting recalled so clearly
his decision-making ability
is questionable let's talk about what
happened with uh snow white so new scene
from disneyland snow white riot is
prompt and backlash fox business story
just days after disneyland
has reopened with an update to its
snow-white attraction the move
is already receiving backlash according
to disney snow white's enchanted
wish takes guests abroad aboard
a wooden mini card as a company the
princess as she escapes the clutches of
the evil queen however it's the
true love's kiss grand finale between
snow white and her prince
that has drawn scrutiny from san
francisco gate the new
grand finale of snow white's enchanting
which is the
most moment when the prince finds snow
white asleep
under the evil queen's spell and gives
her true love's kiss
to release her from enchantment the
outlet writes a kiss he gives to her
without her consent
while she's asleep which cannot possibly
be true love if only one person knows
it's happening
haven't we already agreed that the
consent in early disney movie is a major
issue that teaching kids
that kissing when it hasn't been
established if both parties are willing
to engage
is not okay the san francisco gates said
adam i'm gonna go to you first because i
know you're like
you're with them you agree with them
this is an insult tell us what you think
about the story
well is it is the story from the onion
or is this a real this is a real story
from the
fox business regarding what san
francisco gate had to say about it all
right well
um i'm i'm with i'm with the team you
know the metoo
movement people i understand you know
there's some creepy dudes out there that
you know the harvey weinsteins of the
world the cosby's of the world that have
definitely created this
but let's let's i can't believe this is
even a story let's talk about
all right you're sleeping snow white you
wake up
tell me where you'd like to be mrs white
you want to be in the castle with the
prince
or you want to be in a dwarf motel over
there down the street with seven random
midgets that you're living with i'm
taking the prince bro like
so random midgets i'm just it's not like
she's living a life of life of luxury
some prince shows up sweeps her off her
feet brings her to the castle
little people no you can you make me no
i'm staying i'm staying over here with
these seven little people
in some sort of hostel you want the you
want the you want the castle you want
the hostel
your picks no way the only thing is you
need to be kissed while you're sleeping
so
i'm going with the kiss how do you
process this like actually how do you
process
that's how i process it i'm going with
the prince
random midgets man i was that was that
was drop the mic right there
you know it's literally sleepy and dopey
and grumpy and humpy
healthy yeah exactly you know you've got
these mental problems
people don't think that's a real story i
mean it's disturbing
it's this is cancer culture and it's
fine you know
come on now next thing you know you're
going to cancel prince hakeem from
coming to america this can't happen
no that death of fire will happen my
only hope and my prayer
is that there is a tipping point in this
country where sanity prevails
right and i'm holding out hope that we
will reach that that
threshold because i think more people
have common sense than don't
now there's going to be a market out
there for people that are offended by
this or thinks this is legit
and then let you take out your little
microscopes and look at every piece of
film
that's ever been done in the history of
mankind and by the way is there a
company more woke than disney
now you're trying to cancel a disney
character it's unbelievable you can
never satisfy these people
you will never satiate their appetite to
destroy careers
to destroy history pop culture and that
kind of thing but we don't have to let
them govern us we don't have to
take what they throw down our throat and
say this is right it's wrong it's stupid
just have some common sense and laugh at
it yeah so if you enjoyed this little
short segment from the podcast that we
did here's another short segment to
watch or if you want to see the entire
podcast
click over here take care everybody
[Music]
bye-bye